[Music]
[Music]
oh man the mc who puts emceeing and
emceeing tedious kumar y'all hello how
are we doing
oh my gosh you all are in three
dimensions and i'm in three dimensions
and we're not on a zoom call and it's so
amazing i'm so happy to be here with all
of you my name is anjana vacheel i am a
developer based in san francisco and i
have come all of this way to talk to you
about javascript generators
um the the slides for this talk
including some code examples you can
play around with are on
observablehq.com
anjana so you can play around with it
there because yeah i want to spend the
next half hour talking to y'all about
this really hot new feature from like
six years ago
um
generators and their their companions
iterators which go hand in hand we'll
talk about in a second they're not new
they're not the fresh hotness in
javascript but even though they came
join the javascript party way back in uh
in es6
i feel like we don't talk about them
enough they've been here this whole time
and we haven't really been enjoying them
as much as we should be i think that
generators are super underappreciated i
know there's at least one person in the
audience who agrees with me um
two people
and um i'm hoping to try and uh amend
that a little bit today so we're going
to talk about some things some hopefully
you agree cool things that generators
can do i feel so short i can't see y'all
hi um some cool things that generators
can do and
also i think it's not just that they're
actually useful like you can do
practical things with generators sure
there's always multiple ways to do
things in javascript but generators make
working with things like sequences even
doing uh stuff like async iteration a
lot more comfortable in javascript i
think so they're actually practically
useful but also i love generators
because i think that they're also
amazing teachers
if you don't have a computer science
background like i do not um you might
have some gaps in your knowledge of like
kind of underlying uh computer science
concepts things like control flow things
like
systems programming how processes talk
to each other all that kind of stuff and
it turns out that generators once you
start like reading them up and
duck.going them and digging into the
rabbit hole you
might find that it leads you to a lot of
really interesting understanding of some
underlying computer science concepts so
i think they're not only useful friends
to have in our little toolbox but also
great teachers that we can learn from
and once you start following some of
those rabbit holes i think you might
find they can actually do some pretty
mind-blowing stuff so
that's what i'm hoping we're gonna at
least
scratch the surface of today
um so
before we get into all of the
mind-blowing things that generators can
do let's talk about some basics so what
is a generator well a generator is a
type of iterator
okay cool what's an iterator
so as i said iterators and generators
kind of go hand in hand and an iterator
of which a generator is one
an iterator is just a thing that has a
next method which returns objects of a
certain
shape so any object that has a next
method is an iterator if that next
method returns little objects with a
value property which might have some
useful value a number a string another
object whatever
and then a done property which is a
boolean which indicates whether
iteration is over or not
so when you call the next method on some
iterator
you'll get out a little object that
maybe has a value like something very
and uh also has a done property which in
this case is going to say done false
meaning i still have more iteration to
give
so you call the next method again and
maybe this time you get another thing
same shape of object but a new value the
done property is still false keep going
call next again and eventually you might
get to an object where perhaps you don't
have a value and the done
value is true
because that means now we're done with
iteration here
so um iterators uh and generators are a
type of iterator are useful for doing
iteration you're going to hear me say
the word iterate like 8 000 times today
so prepare
um a few more terminology things while
we're getting uh naming collisions and
confused about the names of things let's
talk about generator functions versus
generator objects so the function star
keyword you've seen it you've seen it
around it's like function it has a star
on it that makes it fancy
it means this is a generator function
and you also notice generator functions
by the fact that they often have a yield
keyword because that's what makes them
useful
so a generator function which is defined
with function star and has yield in it
when we call it it gives us back a
generator object
which has that next method so that's the
iterator so we can call the next method
on that generator object and get out
values now that yield keyword is what's
going to put those values the value
property of the objects returned by the
next method so here i have a very simple
one that just yields one value hello
world when i call next i get that value
done is false and what has happened is
basically
the code is running until here
i yield out that value hello world then
when i call next again
the
code continues running from where it
picked off up at the where where it's
left off picking up at the yield
statement and since there's nothing else
left in my function it's just basically
returning undefined the last value is
undefined and the done value is true now
we're done running this function body
okay so generator functions or turn
generator objects
and um as we just saw but let's look at
a little bit here to see example the
next method when i call that it advances
through the function body of my
generator function until it hits a yield
so here i've got a fun generator
function i'm calling logarator um which
when i instantiate it i get a little
logger object a little generator object
when i call next on that
um javascript starts running the code at
the beginning of the function body so i
get console log running i hear i see
running then it hits the yield
and it pauses
and it returns or it spits out the value
uh after the yield in this case paused
as the value of that object or turned by
the next method but when i call next
again as we said it picks up where it
left off so it starts running right
after that yield uh which means it's
going to log out that running again and
then in this case
it it could maybe have hit another yield
or paused again but in this case it hits
a return or maybe the end of the
function
in this case we can return a value as
well instead of just returning undefined
so that value stopped is going to come
out in the final call to next along with
the done true telling us we're done with
iteration
with me so far
cool
woo yay
all right
y'all are amazing okay um so fun thing
about generators is they're not just
iterators they're also iterables
ah we're gonna get so confused by the
time this is over and i know i'm talking
super fast thank you everyone for
putting up with my super rapid english
we have a lot of cool things to show
about generators so i'm rushing
okay um so generators are also iterable
so here i have a little kind of boring
little generator function abc's it's
going to successively yield letters in
the alphabet abc
the fact that generators are not just
iterate uh they're not just iterators
they're also iterable
means that i can use them in four of
loops or i can use them with the spread
operator same as i could use an array
which is another example of an iterable
in javascript so here if i instantiate
my abcs
i call that function to get my generator
object i can use that in a for of loop
to get out each letter so in this i'm
getting each letter
making it uppercase and logging it out
and i can use them anywhere that
iterable objects can be used including
our handy dandy spread operator so i can
um spread the generator object into an
array and get an array with all of the
values that are yielded out
cool so you might be like why would i
ever do that i could just make an array
with a and b and c in it why would i
write a generator for that well okay for
a small finite uh sequence of letters
you you probably wouldn't but what's
cool about generators being iterables is
that they make it really easy to write
more complex iterable objects
so
let's take a look now now that we've
seen what how generators work let's take
a look at what they can actually do for
us
all right so one really cool thing i
hope folks can see this at the back but
um one really cool thing that you can do
with generator that generators make it
very easy to do
is to create custom iterable objects
so we said that any um any object that
uh
implements the next method can be
an iterator since
generators give us iterators right since
generator functions give us iterators we
can also hook them up to this cool
property called symbol.iterator or the
at iterator method and the way
javascript works since uh all this came
down in es6 is that anytime i try to
iterate over an object with a spread
operator or for of loop or what have you
it's going to look to see
does this object implement this symbol
iterator method
and what i can do is assign the value of
symbol iterator
to any um iterator and in this case a
function star is a great way to create a
new iterator because generators are
iterators so this makes it really easy i
think to create objects that are uh
whatever we want them to be that we can
iterate over simply so here for example
imagine i'm a very lazy programmer and i
need an object that represents a deck of
cards but i don't want to sit out and
enumerate all 52 different card values
so what i've got here is a tiny little
object just a regular object ignore the
parens around those that curly braces
whatever uh is uh i've got the suits
enumerated and i've got maybe the court
cards enumerated i don't need to
enumerate the numbers 2 through 10
because i can just count from i so what
i've got is a little anonymous generator
function which is essentially going
through and computing all the
permutations of the different suits
the numbers 2 through 10 and the
different court cards and it's
successively yielding those out one by
one in traditional dealing order so what
happens then is when i iterate over my
hard deck object just a regular object
keys values properties values um i get
as if i had just written an array with
all of the values they're all there i
promise you all 52 things are in my card
deck even though i didn't have to sit
down and like write those all out
so for more complex or longer or even
infinite sequences the fact that uh
generators help us do lazy evaluation
like this is really useful
okay so that means we can actually do
iteration over infinity
and beyond
so what i've got here i'll uh let you
take a look uh while i take a sip
water let's give it up for water
yeah
man i hope we still have it in 20 years
all right
so
what i've got here is um
a little generator called infinity and
beyond
which has um something which if you're
like me might strike fear into your
heart
a while true
the thing is this wild true has a yield
statement inside of it and remember
yield pauses generators are kind of like
possible functions so i no longer have
to fear the while true because this
won't run infinitely unless something is
infinitely pulling from it by calling
the next method so we can actually do
while true and not break our entire
computer yay
um so what i've got here is an infinite
sequence which is only going to be
evaluated as i request things from it so
lazy evaluation
i've got another little generator um
that's kind of inspired by some
functional programming languages often
have a lot of lazy sequences lazily
evaluated sequences like this and you'll
sometimes find a little utility helper
called take which allows you to take the
first n items from that sequence so take
here is just a little uh also a
generator which is going to take as many
items as i tell it to from a particular
iterable
and so what i can do is like take five
things from infinity just borrow a
little bit from infinity
and since take is also a generator i can
spread that returns a generator i can
spread the result of that into an array
and get an actual workable array from a
potentially infinite sequence now this
is very simple i'm just giving you
numbers but you could also imagine we're
lazily evaluating doing some expensive
computation to get each of these numbers
that i don't want to do for a million
different things all at once i only want
to do it when i actually need them
that means i can also do stuff like
infinite map
so i have a little map generator here
which similarly takes in some iterable
and is going to take some other function
that i want to map over that iterable
and lazily map it so that means i could
actually map over infinity
huh
so what i've got here is a little map a
call to my map generator that's taking
this infinite sequence and
mapping a little function that takes the
square of each number
so now i have an infinite sequence of
squares using my infinite map
and i can use my little take helper to
let's say get the first nine things out
of that
so these are really simple examples but
hopefully you can see that with the
power of the lazy evaluation that that
that pausing each time that we call next
gives us we can actually create like uh
really expensive computations infinite
sequences things that would otherwise
crash our computers
we can work with them just as if they
were arrays in javascript or whatever
other iterable so i think that's pretty
cool
i don't know about you
the other thing that since we can pull
infinitely from generators we can do
really cool things like for example
power animation did you notice these
weird little hopefully no one is uh
uh disturbed by the by the little spinny
uh text animations here um credit to to
my mike mic livestock for that animation
this is an animation that's powered by
generators thanks to the observable
notebook runtime
so um if you haven't checked out
observable it's a pretty cool
environment it works uh in a functional
reactive style so you have little chunks
uh cells of javascript code which are
evaluated reactively and the runtime
what it does is anytime it sees a
generator indicated by the yield
statement it pulls from the next method
of that generator once an animation
frame
so what that means is you can have like
an infinite generator like here this is
one that's built into the observable
environment called uh now which just
keeps yielding the current time the
date.now
and observable pulls from that once an
animation frame so 60-ish times a second
and what that means is then i can use
that value in other things like for
example a little svg
which is using a kind of sine wave based
on that time stamp
to
animate this text animate the svg um
using some utilities there so again you
can check out all this code online but
this is just an example this is probably
not the most common use case but using
these infinite sequences you can do
really cool things when you start
thinking that you have control
over when to pull values out of it
so run times like this are heavy users
of of generators
the other cool thing
is that we have also a yield star
operator have folks seen this
encountered this seen this so yield star
what it does is it works similar to
yield but with an iterable so if i yield
star from an array let's say what it's
going to do is the generator is going to
pretend that it had like yield the first
element yield the second element yield
the third element it's going to
successively yield elements from that
iterable
so what i have here
is an example of how this can power
recursive iteration thanks to
symbol iterator and yield star all right
i have a very simple little data
structure here a binary tree where the
nodes are just teeny little objects what
they have is a value some value some
number some string whatever and they
have that symbol iterator implemented
and that symbol iterator um the value of
that is this uh generator function which
is representing depth first tree
traversal over this binary tree so we're
going to go down a branch and then pop
up and then go down the next branch as
opposed to breadth first
and what this is doing is it starts out
we yield the value of this node
and then if the node has children we use
yield star
to
successively yield the entire subtree
represented by that child node
so what we get then is if we hook up a
bunch of these binary tree nodes into a
tree structure and this is just a very
simple one it's got a couple branches a
couple leaves all made up of these same
binary tree nodes
that means that when i hit yield star on
another tree node it's going to
recursively enter the symbol iterator
property so it's going to recursively
hit this same generator on each of the
child nodes
to give me
this depth first tree traversal that i
just wrote in this one little tiny
little data structure so what i have
here now i've got my little tree object
which is essentially represented by the
root node i can spread that tree i can
do a for of with that tree and i get out
all the values in all of its uh parts
using my depth first traversal i could
also swap out my depth first function
and do a breadth first one and use that
instead so this makes it really nice to
implement um recursive data structures
like this that you can then work with as
if they were arrays right i can just
like do a four of over my tree
try to do that without generators and it
will make you pull your hair out so this
is a fun thing that you might find one
day you actually do want to use at work
or you might just want to play with it
and make silly little trees like this
both valid
all right
so these are some cool things that uh
generators can do and we haven't even
started talking about async yet
so in uh in es6 we got the magic of
generators iterators in es7 we got the
async versions of both
so that means we can start doing all of
the stuff that i just said
asynchronously as well
so in addition to function star we can
now do async function star to get an
async generator function
which we can use a weight in
okay question have folks uh heard of the
star wars api swappy anybody used it in
examples it's really fun it's a public
api that just has a bunch of information
about the star wars universe so for
example you can get all the characters
in the universe or all of the planets or
all of the starships or what have you
and each of these is at a different
endpoint but because there are a lot of
things in the star wars universe those
results are paginated
so what i have here and credit to
luciano mamino for this example
is a little async generator function
which what it does
is it is
loading that paginated data page after
page until it's done so what we've got
is um a little value next url which is
taking in so this is just a little
helper function i've got get swabby
swappy pagerator it's a little helper
function which i'll give it an endpoint
that i'm interested in and it'll give me
back the async generator function that i
need
so what i've got here is um
a little next url which which starts out
with just the base url
and then as i enter a while loop what
i'm going to be doing is fetching each
uh
fetching the results from that url
parsing it as json in that data that i
get back i'm going to have a next url
which is telling me what the following
page is for more results so i'm going to
replace the value my next url and then
i'm going to use my friend yield star
to take the results array which has all
of the objects that i'm interested in on
this page and successively yield them
one after the other using yieldstar
cool
so
what this means is with my little get
swappy pagerator i'm getting the
appropriate async iterator uh sorry
async generator function for each of
these uh different endpoints that i'm
interested in i can now create a little
object that represents the star wars api
um so i can have properties on that
object like a character's property which
itself is an object which all it does is
implement symbol async iterator
and what that does
um and i have the same for a couple
other endpoints what that does is it
tells javascript i can use this in a 408
of loop
so just like for of or the spread
operator when i use it in javascript
javascript goes and looks hey is there
something at symbol.iterator for this
object because then i can use it in the
four of similarly we now have 408 of
which is looking for symbol async
iterator
and so if i implement that i can use my
little objects here
in
this 408 of loop to pretend that this
asynchronously loading paginated data is
coming in as if it was just an array
that i could loop over
okay that's pretty cool right so what
we've got here
thank you thank you to the star wars api
on luciano so what i've got here and
you'll notice so again let's combine
this with the fun thing in observable
where it's going to show me the results
each time there's an animation frame or
each time no new data is available what
i have here is now it looks like just an
array of the ships but i if the
internet's working let's see
we can also see how this could work with
let's say the characters so once i run
this what it's going to be doing and
here i'm yielding things just because
i'm in observable i'm yielding this out
so it'll show up in my screen but you
could also check the console and see
that we're logging these out as they
come in as well so once i run this code
let's see what happens fingers crossed
so first page second page more pages so
on and so forth you can see it coming in
as it does like how cool is that it's as
if it was an array
generators okay
[Applause]
all right so
uh if i've oh i've lost control all
right
so what we've seen
is a bunch of ways that generators can
be really useful to produce serieses of
data
all right so what we have is we have
sequences we have async sequences coming
in we have generators work really nicely
as data producers but
it gets even cooler
because they can also consume data what
just chew on that for a second
[Applause]
water okay um
so yield it turns out and this is an
even less appreciated fact i think than
just generators in general yield is
actually a two-way street
yield doesn't just
give us out those values in the next
method it also receives values from the
next method
so yield can actually function as just
like an expression like pretending it's
a value
in our function body
so here i have a very simple um listener
generator function
which uh when it when i first call when
i instantiate my l object my generator
object when i first call next
this is going to advance until the first
yield right but notice that this yield
now is on the right hand side of an
assignment
what
so you can actually pass in input to the
next method
and the generator will grab that as the
value of the yield where it was paused
what so what happens is the first time
that i run it gets to this yield and so
far it hasn't listened to anything so if
i if i pass in a value on the first call
to next the generator can't hear it yet
because it's at the beginning of its
function body it hasn't gotten to a
yield yet right we said next advances to
the next yield
so when i call it i'm gonna hear okay
i'm listening then when i call next
again with some value
the generator actually got that it's
gonna tell me i heard how about now
and then so on and so forth because
we're in a wild true which again is fine
for like something that we want to be
infinitely listening
um so this is actually really
weird i think and really cool and really
powerful because what that means is that
since generators remember where they
were
they can also function as
state machines we can use them to
represent state right so for example
here i have a little a little generator
function that represents a bank account
i start out with some balance let's say
it's zero i mean if i wanted to i could
put like eight million in there but
it's just integers so not a lot of value
anyway um
so what i what i
have is a little loop that is just
checking to make sure that my balance
doesn't drop below zero and as long as
my balance isn't below zero it's going
to take in transactions as it were the
values i pass into the next method and
it's going to add or subtract those from
my balance but as soon as i hit zero
it's gonna break that loop it's going to
tell me that i'm bankrupt and return and
stop like lock me out of my bank account
i'm no longer able to use this it's over
it's done
all right so here just a little example
i start out i instantiate my account
um i call the next method the first time
i have nothing in there but we're
running
i deposit 50 the value is 50.
then i withdraw 10 it remembered that
the balance was 50 because we're in the
loop of the function body it's just
paused
and it subtracted that 10. so now i have
40. and then if i try to withdraw 60 it
kicks me out because i'm bankrupt but
like
it's just a function and it remembers
where it was because it's not a function
it's a generator function
[Laughter]
so what happened here is the generator
by pausing at that yield and by the fact
that it can then resume using that value
as like an expression in the function
body
generators can yield control
and get it back
so the generator can say hey i'm paused
you just tell me when you want me to
start running again and then when i call
next again it starts running again so
that means generators can
yield control regain control yield
control etc
which means they can function as this
cool thing called co-routines
so now we're getting into the computer
science rabbit holes
um co-routines we can think of as sort
of little uh processes that pass control
back and forth to each other to
cooperate to execute the program
and um i'll leave you with some
resources because i'm running low on
time i'll leave you with some resources
to read more about this because this is
going to be a lot brace yourselves but
what this means is we can do something
uh kind of like actor model programming
have folks heard of the actor model or
like erlang is sort of the the
environment language etc most uh
associated with this it's a really cool
um i would call it paradigm of computing
where you have your your program is made
up of small little entities that we
could call actors or here i'm calling
them players
which send messages back and forth to
each other in order to execute the
program and so then you can have uh some
that are let's say in a more like a
supervisory role that kind of manage the
others and you can have some that are
kind of independently talking to each
other one can die and the others can
keep working and so it's a very cool
model for programming go
go it later all right um
so what we have here is a very simple of
this kind of actor style message passing
using just generators um a little a
little stage setting since it's actors
we have to set the stage so my actors or
my players here i'm just going to keep
track of in a little object so that each
player has a name and then i'm going to
have a message queue where all of the
messages that they're passing to each
other go into this queue and then i can
send them out to the respective
players
as needed so this little send function
essentially
pushes a message onto the queue and then
this run function what it does is it
just keeps
looking for the next thing in the queue
and um
calling the next method on the player
that that message is for the actor that
that message is for
passing in the content of the message
okay
with me so far
ish
okay so what i have now is two actors
that are going to play the knock knock
joke game all right so um i have a
knocker who's going to be passing
messages like knock knock
and i have an asker who's going to be
passing messages like who's there in
response to the knocks from the knocker
so what i have in these two
kind of companion generator functions is
essentially a kind of symmetrical like
one yield to the other the other then is
expecting the message picks up from its
yield statement and so on and so forth
so they can talk to each other
cool
all right so what we have now
if i start if i instantiate my knocker
and my asker and then i send them each
remember we need to call next the first
time before they can listen so i send
them each a message to just get ready
and then i hit run
then what happens if i log this code out
and you can try this at home uh the
knocker goes knock knock and the oscar
goes who's there
gene
gene who
generator
[Music]
yeah
it is the sounds in english don't really
work out but you get it all right um
so
another or my last for i think i'm just
about out of time
but the last thing i want to leave you
with is that this means generators can
even outsmart their own environment
generators can help us outsmart
javascript which is one of my hobbies is
um escaping recursion limits
so i don't know folks have heard of tail
call optimization that's another way you
can escape some of the recursion limits
in javascript i have another talk about
that but um you might have seen in your
uh in your in your travelings in
javascript land you might have seen
things like uh call stack size exceeded
uh too much recursion
um stack overflow so this happens among
other things when we do a too much or
too deep or infinite recursion
and um
that can happen not just when i have a
recursive function that calls itself but
also when i have two functions that call
each other infinitely
what we have is an example of mutual
recursion so neither of these functions
is recursive on its own but together
they keep going ping pong ping pong ping
pong adding numbers to the number that
they're of pings that they've done
forever and eventually i'll hit the
stack stack overflow too much recursion
what have you error
but remember how our actor model let us
make little actors that talk to each
other
so we can actually do
a ping pong version using generators
which will keep going forever
thanks to this little actor model mini
actor model environment that we've
implemented so here instead of my
knocker and my asker i just have a ping
and a pong which are just sending
increasingly higher numbers back to each
other
and when i run this
after initializing them i just start
things off by sending the first ping
with zero and
be careful if you want to run this make
sure nothing else valuable is happening
on your computer at the time
but what'll happen is it'll just keep
going until
my browser explodes like it can actually
escape the javascript stack size limit
so i don't know but this is again a
hobby of mine is uh trying to trick
javascript into doing things it really
doesn't want to do and generators can do
that for us so yay thanks generators
thanks actor model
okay
sorry that we're a couple minutes over
but to sum up
the
practical uses that we've seen for
generators they can help us implement
our own custom iterable data structures
those could be lazy evaluated those
could be infinite those could be um even
recursive like we saw before we can use
generators to
remember states so we can they we can
treat them like state machines we can do
data processing with them
we can even kind of power streams with
data and that async data loading is kind
of a hint at the fact that
streams are coming down hopefully we're
gonna have easier uh ways of working
with streams uh they're in proposals and
uh that is all based on this kind of
async iteration that we've seen
and we saw some cool computer science
concepts so we talked about control flow
about co-routines passing uh information
back and forth and essentially doing
co-op multitasking we talked about the
actor model you can even use generators
to learn about functional programming
things like the m word
so i'm going to leave you all with some
um resources i'll uh the slides all have
the links online but there's a great
talk um from from back in the es6 day by
bottle stoke about the miracle of
generators and there's some excellent
resources on generators in python as
well which python has had generators
since you know the dawn of time as far
as i know and uh we can learn a lot from
that community too so lots of great
resources out there you can find them
all in my slides on observable sorry to
be have run over but i just had to tell
you about generators
thank you all so much thank you jscon
for having me
it's amazing